you know look you talked about this you
said what you said there was a lot it
was it was a big thing with joss whedon
on set
and you know the whole
um
way
castmates were treated was it something
you were privy to something that you
noticed something that or was did you
always just feel like he was just a
a tough guy knew what he wanted was
intense what was it like for you you're
i'm not saying that you're you don't
agree or you agree with whatever
everyone had their own expectations
i'm not going to tell them
exactly that you're not telling what but
your experience i'm going to new york
city yeah my experience because i
remember you telling me in the first
interview that there was a time where he
kind of put you against the wall and
said something to you and that was like
you know
i said
he he was joking
and you go no
so maybe just recap that briefly but
then go into what your perception was
yeah so uh just
in in josh's world evil is not cool and
i really respect him for that uh
vampires were just a metaphor for the
challenges that you get over in your
adolescence so vampires are supposed to
be overcome
and uh he got talked into one
sexy vampire that's not going to be
killed off that was angel and i was
supposed to come in and get killed off
and
uh the audience immediately reacted to
me in a way that that made it
was gonna make it very difficult to kill
me off and the network was telling them
oh my god keep this guy in the show and
all of that and he's like you're
i was basically
ruining his show
basically forcing him to keep you on
because you were doing so well
yes but the thing is is that
that is going to change the show from
being about a teenager overcoming
adolescence
into a show where
where those problems are kind of sexy
aren't they all those
all this this this psychotic
i was killing people all the time i was
shredding them and then the audience was
going oh we want more of that and josh
is like no no the point is that you
overcome the evil that's the point so
if i was in his shoes i would have
killed me off i wouldn't have pushed me
against the wall i do wish i just would
have killed him off immediately saying i
know i told you five episodes will pay
you for five but you're dead after two
sorry that's what i would have done but
he didn't do that no he didn't he just
got frustrated and figured it out but
there was that day when he
he pushed me up against the wall well
how did how did it start did he
immediately go up to you i don't
remember how you don't remember it's it
you know i just want people there
yeah yeah and and he's in my face he
goes i don't i don't care how popular
you are kid you are dead you are dead
you are dead you got me
but you never were dead but he didn't
yeah because he
so you make a slight smirk to it there
was a but you're dead you're dead
no i just said it's your football dude
you got you did you did you want to do
it
you know i i'm not i'd come off of
producing so i was always on the side
i'm always on the side of production so
right uh uh but your experience on set
like that you can remember like you're
sitting there and you're in your head
because remember you just told me you're
kind of a loner you're kind of doing
your own thing so i don't know what you
saw but there were peripherally where
they're kind of little things that
you're like oh that's pretty intense or
that's
two things first i kind of i kind of
thought of him as a mad was like as a
wizard
like able to create magic and here's
another amazing thing but also like you
know don't piss off gandalf because he
might you know snap yeah or i don't know
snap well
tell you exactly what he's thinking you
know but i just remember one time i went
up to him and i said you know
it must be wonderful to to wind up this
universe and watch it play out
it's not exciting and he goes yeah it's
great james except i have to keep
winding and so he put an enormous amount
of pressure on himself and so i i saw
his
his uh
intensity
as that as as trying to accomplish
something that was a very high bar and
that he most of all put
the pressure on himself to deliver that